Drinking on a Tuesday morning DOESN'T MAKE
you an alcoholic, but science is working on
understanding the thing that does.
Hey everyone!
Trace here for DNews.
Alcoholism is a downer of a topic, but it's
important to understand how addiction is formed
and reinforced.
As we've learned more, the idea behind addiction
has changed.
In the early 20th century, addiction was thought
to stem from a lack of willpower, but as medical
technology advanced and we began to understand
how physiological addiction worked, the idea
of addiction changed.
The pervading wisdom today is addiction is
created in the brain because drugs, like alcohol,
override the brain's reward center called
the limbic system.
According to the current model, the delivery
of dopamine from the limbic system REORGANIZES
a healthy brain into a DRUG-ADDLED DEMON BRAIN.
The drug initiates a coup of the executive
function -- people with addiction are physiologically
unable to abstain from their habit.
Their brain has to get them high.
Most of the literature calls it a hijacking!
This is where people get the idea of drugs
being SUPER addictive even with only ONE USE.
The problem is, scientifically, there's not
a lot of evidence for this.
In reality, two people could both use heroin
once, and one will go on with their life and
be fine, but the other might seek it out again
and again.
A new study in PLOS One is changing attitudes
even further by finding a small part of the
brain might be a major trigger for addictive
behavior in rats.
The lateral habenula is deep in the middle
of the brain, and when the rats had theirs
selectively destroyed -- they could no longer
tell if the decisions they were making were
harming themselves or others.
Basically, they'd lost the ability to feel
the consequences of their actions.
Rats were given the option to enjoy a 40 proof
alcoholic drink, and water.
They chose the alcohol thanks to the lovely
dopamine wave that comes with being drunk.
But, once they were wasted, they didn't stop
drinking it, they didn't moderate their behavior,
and once they'd sobered up enough, they went
right back to it.
The researchers believe the lateral habenula
could be responsible for the internal monologue
for which asks, "How bad was my drinking last
night?
I should back off for a while, I need to make
sure this isn't a problem."
According to this new study, addiction isn't
solely about the brain's reward center, there's
also an internal moderation of the effects
of that reward.
They're not saying people with a bad lateral
habenula ARE addicts; rather that with more
information, a genetic profile could be established
and we could tell who'd be in a high risk
group for addiction!
That information could help people and their
families make responsible life decisions.
Do you know someone with addiction?
How have you helped?
Share your experiences with us, people are
strongest together.
Tell us about it down in the comments and
subscribe for more DNews videos every day!
We even have a Vine now!
So you can see things like that time Joe Bereta
hit me in the face with a pillow!